hi my name is avita if you're doing well
today i'll be taking you to infinity and
beyond with my first impressions and
review of light years so it's the new
movie by disney and pixar if you grew up
on the toy story films like i did you
would not need any sort of introduction
to buzz lightyear is now this movie is
actually separate from the toy story
movie um even though yes it's based on
the character okay so just to like put
things simply this movie is the movie
that andy from toy story watched that
made him fall in love with the character
and then buy the toy
yeah it's pretty metal if you think
about it but
let me just go through this with you
[Music]
so i think if you're going into like
you're expecting it to feel like toy
story especially if you grew up on toy
story you might be a little bit let down
like yes 100 this movie is meant for
kids who grew up in the 90s i mean we're
attached to the character we want to see
the character i don't think the average
kid today would care so much about who
buzz lightyear is right like i am
expecting the theaters to be full of
people like us who grew up watching toy
story
who possibly have kids and bring our
kids to the movies
but it's nothing like that that being
said you don't really need to be a toy
story fan to catch this movie too
you don't need to like watch all four
toy story movies to also get this movie
lightyear is really a movie of its own
as much as some fans might not be happy
with that i actually really like that
sentiment because if you think about it
this is a character that we've known for
27 years it feels like we know the guy
we grew up with the guy but there's
still so much that we don't know there's
a whole other life a whole other like
crazy adventure that we've not seen and
i like that it's like the toy story
universe is slowly expanding and i'm a
fan of that and i think that's what this
movie does really well is that it brings
in characters that we all know and love
we grew up watching them so there's a
lot of nostalgia there but they give you
something new to work with it's
something fresh it's something different
so it's not a rehash right like if you
come into this movie thinking yeah it's
just gonna be like another toy story
type of vibe it's not same characters
different characterizations simply put
okay so the main gist of the movie is
that buzz lightyear goes on a mission
and what feels like a few minutes
actually is a few years for those living
on the planet with every hero story you
need a villain i'm not gonna say who the
villain is i feel like if you've watched
toy story you
kind of already know who he is so in
order to complete his mission buzz liara
comes together new crew of people who
are you know what complete bumbling
foods they are just unhelpful
they are rookies and if you know
anything about buzz you know that he's
like a one-man team he's like i'm doing
this myself i mean even buzz is
completely different right like firstly
his voice by chris evans is it alton
allen
suddenly he has hair he's like all
mcdaddied up um suddenly that's like
you're sexy who said that not me
anyway
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
circulators especially the all-new 2022
titan evo with its revamped 4-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support if pu
leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely frost blue the tyson evo is
even magnetized along the hit pillow to
stick on the headrest of course there
are even more new features so do check
them out at secretlab.co
so this bus lightyear is a complete
deviation from the buzz lightyear using
the toy story films and i like that the
reason why i like it is because they
make it seem more
human it makes buzz feel a lot more
believable you know like in the toy
story films whenever they go through
something really dangerous
like
yeah it's emotional whatever but at the
end of the day they're still toys like
they're not even alive in the first
place so they're not really like
dead they're not really alive so like
even when they die like are they really
dead gets philosophical up in here but
because this movie makes buzz seem like
an actual human being whose actions
breed consequences
like when he gets himself in danger
you're like oh my god like is he gonna
live is he gonna survive and
that's part of the big action i don't
think there's ever a long moment in this
movie too like there's just so much
action so much adventure
if i'm being honest it gives me a little
bit of like style advice or like star
trek vibes no i know you're probably
wondering chris evans as buzz liar or
tim allen as buzz lightyear i'm so sorry
chris baby but i gotta say tim ellen
still wins and i think that's just
because
i don't think anyone can really
replicate or replace
the iconic buzz lightyear that tim ellen
brought to life i mean he was that
character for 27 years like who can
never beat that
but that's not to say that chris isn't a
good buzz i think he brings his own
flavor to the character chris was really
able to play this really like men of
duty this like
really straightforward guy no nonsense
and if you think about it it's kind of
like his character captain america
is all about honor all about doing
things right and christmas at will so
that's the buzz that we get in this
movie now i think the star of the show
is socks it's the cute little cat that
um hangs out with lightyear in the
trailers and he is a big part of the
movie too i think it's pretty damn clear
that sox is going to be like every
viewer's favorite character is like the
grogo
to the mandalorian so it's like socks
and buzz lightyear i don't want to say
too much because i think i'll just let
you fall in love with the character
itself but if you leave the cinema
without having an inch of love for socks
you have issues but let's talk about
that big bad villain for a bit i mean if
you grew up on the movies you know who
zerg is
um
let me just tell you this whatever you
know about that guy
out the window like
you think you know a guy you think you
know the main story between buzz and
zerk you don't okay there's something
completely new here i don't want to
spoil it for you but it's like an insane
twist like my jaw was to the floor
because i did not expect that let's talk
about new characters okay so we have
alicia hawthorne voiced by uzo aduba who
spiritually orange is the new black and
then we also have easy hawthorne which
is the granddaughter of alicia
voiced by kiki palmer we also have um mo
marinson who is voiced by taika ytt
these are like the main crew the main
people that you see buzz interact with
throughout the whole movie now i
freaking love the friendship between
alicia and buzz it's very like
co-workers turn best friend type of vive
um you'll see where and how buzzyman
came up with the whole idea of light to
infinity and beyond it's like it's
really heartwarming um
alicia is also an lgbt character which
is beautiful to see i mean we love
seeing representation
and then we have izzy who is
she's really young i think in the movie
mentioned that she was 22 or like 23
years old she's still figuring herself
out but she loves and adores her
grandmother and she just wants to be the
next alicia so you see buzz and alicia
have this like best friend
relationship and then you see buzz and
izzy have this very small like
mentor-ish relationship i think it's
really beautiful that we see different
types of relationships in this movie
um and it's not just like one standard
like
man falls in love with women
taika is mo
it's
he is
pretty much takeaway tt i don't know
like when i watched that film i saw the
characterization of mo i thought
yeah this could be taika just funny
clumsy
makes mistakes unapologetic
um i think he is one of a
he's a character that really grows onto
you as the film progresses
and oh my god how can i forget dale
souls as darby who is this like really
bad ass grandma in the team she's an
amazing character she's really tough
she's really salty
you see her interact with mo more i
think darby and mo provide a lot of like
comic relief in this film
but
that's pretty much it and i think they
challenge buzz to grow the challenge was
to change the way he thinks about how
people should be or how people should
behave and yeah i mean they make a
really beautiful team together it's
it's like a big band of misfits that
come together to do a space mission and
i don't think we can hate on that
in all i think lightyear is a very
enjoyable film if you love the space
genre you would love this film if you
love star wars or star trek you'll find
little bits and pieces here and there
chris evans really brought like a brand
new version of buzz that we've never
seen and i like that i mean
i think there's so much potential for
lightyear to be
a big franchise too i mean i would love
to see
buzz and izzy and the rest of the game
go on crazy space adventures and like i
don't know like star trek level
adventures who knows i think it'll be
amazing if disney pixar also taps into
like all the other toy story characters
i would love to see a woody film i would
love to see a jessie film i would
actually really love that and maybe even
mystery mrs potato head i mean
i don't know let me really cute romance
film anyways these are my thoughts about
light year let me know in the comment
section below if you love it if you hate
it i'm more than happy to have a chat
with you remember to like this video
subscribe to us on youtube and follow us
on our social media accounts this is
avita signing off
[Music]
you